thomas athées ou merde ces choses et
marciano c'est quoi ce bordel où est ta
main on est allé chercher à la sortie de
son école j'aimerais récupérer le sac de
quoi tu me parles
ce sont dans les vies dit-il aux
hameaux si tu touches à un cheminement
je leur rends la saq et je récupère mon
fils mairesse et ma mère je croule sous
les dettes tiens absolument besoin de ce
fric
work and find pareil tu prends des sacs
en plastique du meedat farine dedans
j'ai pris l'initiative de suivre dans
son garage il est dans une boîte
retrouvée vous lâcher plus je dois
regarder votre sac à main tiens ça te
fais ça c'est bon on lit
encore nokia séminaire voix
qu'est ce que t'as foutu le bordel de
file dans ta boîte à joseph c qui
s'ignore et quand tu sais plus à quoi
parce que je suis flic
[__] c'est quoi cette merde j'ai une
tête à faire des crêpes ou encore c'est
vincent qui nous a baisé conflit crêpes
whaou
j'ai encore son fils
celui-ci sortira jamais ici
non
après j'espère qu'ils d'essence
la seule chose qui compte dans la vie